في المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي يعتمد
اقتصادها على النفط وهي اكبر مصدر للنفط
في العالم من سيشرح لنا وجهه النظر الشارع
السعودي عن الانخفاض في اسعار النفط افضل
من سعودي يقود سياره
اجره عبد الله العتيبي ودث عش طفلا يجني
50 ريالا سعوديا اي ما يعادل 15 دولارا في
اليوم ماذا تشتري لك هذه
والله تقضها من البقاله تقضى طماط بصل لبن
يقول لي عبد الله ان الوضع كان افضل لكن
الان الوضع صعب فهو يحتاج الى دخله من
سياره الاجره بالاضافه الى راتبه العسكري
التقاعدي فاحما دون الاخر لن يتكفل بدفع
فواتير الكهرباء والهاتف وغيرها في المطار
حيث التقي به هناك الكثيرون مثله يحاولون
التوفيق بين اوقات عملهم ينتظرون او
ينامون
يقول عبد الله ان السبب هو العدد الكبير
من السائقين الوافدين بالاضافه الى شركه
السيارات الاجره الكبيره والتي تجذب
الزبائن بعيدا عن سيارات الاجره المستقله
ويضيف انهم بحاجه للاهتمام بالسعوديين
اولا وفي رحلتنا مررنا بمشكله اخرى تعبئه
البنزين فبعد تخفيض الدعم في خدمات
الكهرباء والماء والنفط قفزت اسعار
البنزين من 60 سنتا الى ما يقرب من دولار
كامل
للجالون
الصعوبه ما هي في البنزين ولا في الصحيح
ان البنزين هو الارخص في بلدنا ولكن تخفيض
الدعم يجعل دفع فواتير اصعب بكثير في
العام الماضي استهلكت المملكه ما يقرب من
100 مليار دولار من الاحتياطيات ما زال
لديها الكثير لكن تخفيض الدعم هو واحد من
العديد من الاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه ولي ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان يقود المملكه باتجاه التحرر من
اعتماد اقتصادها على النفط فقد اقترح
مؤخرا خصخصه بعض الشركات التابعه الم بما
فيها الشركه التي قد تصبح الاكبر في
العالم ارامكو شركه النفط
السعوديه لا يعرف عبد الله الكثير من
التفاصيل لكنه موافق ان نفذت التغييرات
بالطريقه الصحيحه ويقول انها يجب ان تكون
لصالح السعوديين فهو يامل بمستقبل افضل
لاطفاله